they're more likely to think more
emotionally well and women
i mean modern women are side chicks
because i mean we swipe on five to
twenty percent of
tinder likes and the majority of people
meet online
so
we're all picking the same guys and then
come and then crying that we get cheated
on it's like you picked up but do you
know what i think is is hilarious we
started this whole thing saying
oh does society
accept men or are men not loved
care about men
if no one cares about men who are the
men going out and cheating
it's a small percentage of men well most
men can't you can't get anyone one out
of three men haven't had sex in the past
year and even if they get married 20 of
them don't even get sex anyway the
average guy like i said the average guys
dms are dry yeah the average guy doesn't
get attention from women when women know
you as women know you can walk out of
your house
with a bonnet on and track suit bottoms
and still garner attention from men and
is there anything stop no hang on hang
on hang on i'm saying men don't get that
so
the reason why what we're saying is that
there's a small percentage of men that
are getting most of the women
and most of the women are going for
those men women the majority of men
engage women rate eighty percent of men
as unattractive not okay unattractive
where men swipe right fifty percent of
the time yeah that's because
half a time they're looking for one
thing like
if you're coming if you're online and
you swipe a guy you could not think he
only saw your picture and swiped you
like of course he's been swiping
swapping men are that possibility the
more you swipe than what someone's going
to pick you women are left definitely a
lot more picky in in that sense so
yeah i mean it's going to bounce to
happen i don't think if you take men
online serious then boy but you're
you're moving the goal post because the
whole point is that like men and women
are different and men don't the average
guy doesn't get any attention from women
ever so what stops the average guy from
being a one percent guy oh this is
because there's things that stop women
like women if you're not the right
face
if you're not the right shape of
yourself
if you're not like okay bbl you can get
you can get plastic surgery
on top on top of that you can be in the
top 20 of women if you're just in really
great shape because most women are
overweight here and in the u.s
do men look at women for that their
their their shape or maybe like the face
i mean i mean it depends on the guy but
a lot of guys will take a girl with a
great body and an okay face like a lot
of guys 100 percent yeah men do but i
think if okay if that as long as men
make money
sorry as long as men make money what is
the issue the issue is you make money
you can do what you want right so if you
just make the money you do what you want
and that's how hard it is for you no but
the thing is you're not understanding
that we live in a generation now where
women are telling men
or are giving men unrealistic or giving
themselves and men unrealistic
expectations for the money that you're
talking about right so the average man
will earn 45k
right women are talking about oh they
want a man with six figures and he's
gotta be this and he's gotta be six foot
tall when you talk about men being six
foot tall it's only what less than
fifteen percent of men are six foot tall
right so you you're you're
you're pricing yourself out of the
height you're pricing yourself out of
the money so these average dudes which
aren't six foot and they don't make 100k
they're the ones that are walking around
like what about me but a woman would go
with me like what about me average
height man
if he earned enough for for the right
price so
i don't think height is that okay so
most of these guys i of put it when
girls are looking online
they're looking in a very logical way so
they get working with like a shopping
list right so it's only those guys who
are
who are maybe under six foot who don't
have that money who have the confidence
and the skill
to me to go in person who can overcome
that
and it's also
women are incentivized to catch a kid or
a bag from a dude
so like yeah he could have money but
like the majority of the women the
world's richest women are all from
divorce
i mean well if the average man is
earning 45k i'd like i think trapping an
average man wouldn't be great would it
because i might say that again you said
women are incentivized they're rewarded
for bad behavior and you said something
about the richest women and on the
planet or the majority of them got their
money from divorce because because women
are incentivized to divorce men and get
kids off of them
yeah they're rewarded which is why
divorce rate eighty percent of divorces
are initiated by women in the us it's 90
if you're college educated over here
it's 64 percent
of women that initiate divorces so it's
the women that are saying well you know
what i don't want any more and a lot of
the time they get a bag out of it they
get house they get cars they get the
children
it's good so it's it's it's but are they
happy and i think and i think if men if
if society really did care about men
then the the laws around
marriage would be very very more uh
british 50 50
women that make those laws
they cater towards yeah they cater to
women
why
why because women win elections
like that's it's interesting because a
lot of the election strategies are
similar to the marketing strategies that
they use and women make 70 to 80 of
consumer buying decisions so
men know that if they want to get
elected they can run on certain issues
and manipulate women emotionally like
for example like roe versus wade
they can just run on that and then women
will come cry into the polls oh no let
me kill my kid
yeah that went
very well
it's true
it's true
it's like that's
that's like a woman's right now you know
like we talk we've spoken about grape in
on and off yeah the show right yeah and
did you guys know that one in 20 people
that are graped i mean
i didn't know that yeah one in five
years
yeah and obviously men are less likely
to
um
speak about it it's funny because i say
it's funny because even on here there
was a guy on here a few weeks ago who
said that he had like an essay situation
i'm not gonna lie i was listening to it
i was like
really and i had to check myself like
wow like i'm really questioning that and
i'm a man so you're not supposed to
believe him
well i was supposed to at least like
hear him out but when i heard it i was
like ah but then i was like oh my god
if you look at it from the same
standpoint that that women would would
consider essay then yeah it happens
daily when it comes to women to men like
it happens all the time you know i've
definitely had
women come up to me and just sort of go
grab you go for the crap
i think if i said then exactly i just
went like that that's that's is that
essay then would you say if a woman does
that to you i would well
dude
he's like i wouldn't i want to marry
this way it's difficult because
technically it is by the standards that
women have set but i actually think
lesbians get away with that as well
well like ellen she got away with i
can't remember who she groped but she
did grope someone in the picture without
their consent mm-hmm um so and i think
so basically women are allowed to go
wait dude
did that person press charges
no but they did look uncomfortable
but i'm saying if yeah okay it's like
then press charges i think like i just
don't i don't just believe people just
because they say things like anyone can
say something go press charges yeah and
also